if you're trying to figure out what you
want to do in life and people tell you
that you need to follow your passion and
explore your options I'm going to give
you some practical advice on how to
actually do that in today's video I'm
Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I
recently posted a video talking about
how if you don't know what you want to
do in life you need to discover your
passion and the best way to start is to
explore explore different ideas and
options and seeing which one you fall in
love with and you can turn into a
potential business I saw after posting
that I got a question for one of my
YouTube readers love you guys stunned
down who wrote to say can you elaborate
a bit on how to explore happy face so
this is a fantastic question and I'm
gonna give you three main ways and
strategies that I use to explore that I
hope can help you in your journey
number one is look for activities and
communities what I look for is groups of
people who are doing things that you've
never done before that you may have had
an interest in and see if you can join
up with them to learn as an example
every weekend my system prepares for me
a list of all the things that are
happening in my city of Toronto in City
and I look at the things that are on
that list of activities happening and
try to explore them and try to go to
them and see if I'm going to enjoy them
or not and see if it's something that I
wanted to learn about and curious about
and I try to take the approach and the
mindset that maybe I can learn something
from this I don't know anything about
this industry or this culture so I'm
gonna go and explore and it's led me to
go to the sex show and the RV show on
the same weekend I've gone to vegan
shows and different cultural shows I've
gone to dancing shows I've expanded my
range my realm of knowledge and what I'm
comfortable doing and not doing and
every time I go out I find a way to
apply it to my life somehow so instead
of adopting the mentality thinking oh
that's not nuts not for me I'm never
gonna be interested in that explore
right you're an exploratory mode find
things that are happening every weekend
in your city and go and join them go to
meetups go to events look at calendars
that were being put out by your city or
by local groups and just go for the
first time and see if you like it or not
you don't know until you try number two
is say
more if friends invite you to things
things that you've never done things
that might be scary things that again
you may feel like ah
that's not for me just say yes go try it
out here's an example recently a friend
of mine Christians from the company
happy worker invited me to go
tree-planting with him and his wife and
his son and I've never gone
tree-planting before ever so I said why
not let's go and try it and we had fun
we had a blast I brought my son I
brought my wife and we had fun planting
trees when I first got into salsa
dancing is because a girl that I was
interested in wanted to try salsa
dancing so I said yes let's go and try
it out and see if we like it when I
first got in the snowboarding's because
my wife her then girlfriend at the time
said why don't we go snowboard and she
had done it before she wanted to take me
so I said yes let's go and try it so say
yes more unless you know with absolute
certainty that you're gonna hate it
say yes and try it out and that's a
great way to explore to see if you
discover something that you're
interested in and you love doing or not
number three is quick starts and quick
exits the idea behind exploring is
finding something that you love to do
something you can get lost in thing
something that you're curious about
something that may not even make sense
on paper but when you get into it you
just love it so much you're gonna have
fun and you want to keep going back to
it but if you don't love it that's cool
you never have to go back to doing it
again
I tried rock climbing and I hated it and
I'm probably never gonna back to doing
it again
I tried snowboarding and I liked it and
it was fun and we go you know a couple
of times a year and that's about it
I tried camping and I liked that and I
go a couple times a year and that's fine
tree planting I just tried I enjoy that
and I'll probably go once or twice a
year salsa dancing I tried and I loved
it and I fell in love with it and even
though it looked terrible on paper right
I'm too tall I don't speak Spanish you
don't understand the music I never heard
it before I'm not a dancer I'm learning
as an adult all these reasons why this
shouldn't be something that I'm excited
about I get into and and I loved it and
I had to find a way to keep going and
now fast-forward over a decade later I'm
an instructor I'm a DJ a professional
dancer I've invested into a salsa
dancing company and so you don't
until you explore that whole thing
started just because a girl that I was
interested in seeing she wanted to go do
salsa dancing and I just said yes you
never know what's gonna work out just
got to go out and explore and try my
last bonus tip on this is keep an open
mind because I look back to that salsa
example and if I went into that looking
at it as a business opportunity right if
I said I don't know what I'm gonna do
next in my life I need to find the next
business opportunity they need to jump
into I would look at it and say now
there's all these users why salsa isn't
gonna work out and then I wouldn't even
try but I went in with an open mind I
went in not looking specifically for
business opportunity and it became one
it's like when you start a business just
trying to make money you really do but
if you start a business because you love
what you're doing and you're really
helping people that's when you start to
make a lot of money so get out of your
head
stop figuring all the reasons why
something's not gonna work out and just
try and see if you fall in love so those
are my three tips for how to explore and
find your passion for those you've
watching I'd love to know how you've
explored and how you found your passion
leave it in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion and if you liked
this video and you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and the newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon